der sprecher des bundesverbandes der
kinder- und jugendärzte heißt zwar
ausgerechnet mit nachnamen maske dennoch
fordert er jakob maske den alltag für
kinder und jugendliche nach monaten der
entbehrung so normal wie möglich zu
gestalten und das obwohl viele kinder
gerade mit schniefen der nase und husten
in die kitas kommen weil sie nach corona
wieder mehr kontakt untereinander haben
er die biologin und regierungsberater in
melanie brinkmann wiederum hält diese
forderung der kinderärzte nach einer
lockerung der masken pflicht für so
wortwörtlich dumm das wiederum hält
philippi adhoc bild meinung chef für
wenig schlauch guten morgen philipp der
guten morgen also melanie brinkmann
virologin am helmholtz-institut und seit
vielen vielen monaten noch eine enge
beraterin das kanzleramt schaltet sich
mal wieder in die korona debatte ein und
macht das wirklich mit der arroganz der
macht wie man sie aus der wissenschaft
eigentlich nicht kennt und diese macht
zieht sie aus ihrer funktion als
kanzleramts beraterin wann hört man dass
das wissenschaftler einander als dumm
als ziemlich dumm abkanzelt kanzel und
das auch noch in einem autorisierten
interview das ist nichts flapsiges was
ihr mal rausrutscht und wir erleben dass
leider zunehmend in diesem corona
beraterstab des kanzleramts frau bringt
man ist nicht die einzige die sich
solche ausfälle leistet auch ehrlich
gesagt professor christian drosten der
hat auch schon den virologen hendrik
stricken die nähe von querdenkern
gerückt also das ist ein ton in der
debatte dem man sich eigentlich
verbietet also man spricht natürlich
gerne über die radikalisierung in der
gesellschaft aber ich würde mir auch
wünschen dass die wissenschaftler vor
allem jene die das kanzleramt beraten
einmal ein bisschen runterkommen und
auch anfangen andere meinungen zu
tolerieren weil alles was virologen
sagen ist ja auch die rein biologische
perspektive der kinder erst zu sprechen
tun sie das vielleicht auch indem sie
die nebenwirkungen der masken pflicht
die wirkung der masken pflicht auf
kinder abseits von corona mal auswerten
oder auch die haben eine sehr legitime
haltung und ich glaube wenn man anfängt
und in der wissenschaft einander als
dumm zu bezeichnen dann läuft wirklich
sehr kräftig wird daneben und wir müssen
ja auch mal auf die schauen die das
jetzt auch wirklich betrifft also die
schülerinnen und schüler in den klassen
die er natürlich jetzt verwirrt er denn
je sind was ist denn nun richtig die
schüler werden ja das machen was in den
landesverordnung steht hier geht es
ausschließlich darum was soll die
politik entscheiden und
es fällt mir schwer zu verstehen warum
dass ich deine kanzleramts beraterin
hinstellt die er wissen muss was für
eine autorität sie eigentlich hat und
was für ein debattenstil sie eigentlich
prägen sollte und kanzelt so eine
forderung und die forderung ist ja
wirklich nicht radikal die sagt nur
masken pflicht für schüler weg weil
erwachsene abends im lokal sitzen dürfen
ohne die maske zu tragen das ist doch
nicht um diese frau bringt man das
letztens in einem doppel interview im
spiegel neben eher ein verhaltensökonom
und er hat gefordert dass ungeimpfte
menschen aus dem krankenhaus abgewiesen
werden sollten ja also eine unglaubliche
sanktionsmaßnahmen da hat sie nicht
widersprochen hat sie nicht gesagt oh
das ist aber dumm aber hier wenn
kinderärzte must die abschaffung der
masken pflicht fordern dann platzt ihr
der kragen das finde ich wirklich fatal
[Musik]